okay so we are catching back up with the
Wolverine comics and one of the things
to remember here a little bit of ketchup
that Wolverine was basically taken by
the X-Men Beast who'd become more and
more extreme to the point that he's just
a straight-up villain and Wolverine was
being used by Beast to essentially kill
anybody that stood against the mutant
population now eventually Wolverine was
able to break free of that control and
where we are right now is that Beast has
effectively taken off that the main base
of operations known as the point for the
X-Force team which is basically the
mutant's version of the CIA that that
was actually a giant being right just a
giant robotic type being that Beast had
built and then he left and took off to
the ocean floor the reason for that is
that being so far underwater that no one
can really track him and so this allows
beasts to basically operate with
impunity the other part of this is that
Wolverine did eventually catch up to
beast and he did kill him but what we
found out is that ever The Genius of the
X-men group Hank McQueen had
redundancies that as soon as he was
killed a duplicate immediately emerged
right in like like literally his death
triggered the activation of a clone of
himself that clone emerges with all the
memories of Beast intact including
exactly how it was if he was killed and
he gets to work on producing more of
himself now what we end up finding out
here is that in addition to duplicating
himself what Beast has also done is he's
cloned Wolverine now here's one of the
big caveats when it comes to this and
Marvel doesn't really explain this one
of the big questions people have had is
that whenever Wolverine is killed and
the X-Men resurrect him and bring him
back to life how does he get his
adamantium back so that is due to a
member of the five right the five
mutants that resurrect dead mutants
bring him back to life one of those guys
is named Proteus he has the ability to
alter reality but only in a really small
space say for example maybe the size of
your house and so this allows him to
literally alter reality and to create
adamantium strictly for a wolverine it's
only done on that basis him or like
Laura Kinney x23 nobody else gets it if
they're not supposed to have it Beast
seemingly does not have that ability so
we don't know exactly how it is he was
able to clone Wolverine and bring his
adamantium in without having someone
like Proteus that can do a form but
regardless of how you slice it what
Beast does is he starts sinning
Wolverine yet again after all these
people that are either stealing from
cocoa that politically stand against
krakowa anybody who is against the
mutant population in some form or
fashion but he's sending in all the
Wolverines at one time now the reason
why this is so effective and the reason
why it works is that Beast learned from
his previous actions that when he had
Wolverine the main Wolverine under his
control he was basically mindless he was
like a feral version so he would just go
running in and just attack things by
having like five versions of Wolverine
out there it allows one guy to eliminate
the Target and then it allows the other
four to be Lookouts for anything else
that needs to be destroyed or to allow
them all to operate at the same time on
so instead of relying on one Wolverine
to take out the target then take out the
cameras then remove any evidence that he
was there or anything like that all five
can do it in a fraction of the time so
it's a very very efficient system not
only that these are just the five that
are here there's like others that are
consistently being created by beasts in
case any one of those five are destroyed
and so for the prime Wolverine himself
after killing Beast he literally takes
his body and he brings it directly to
the quiet Council the governing body of
the mutant population in Marvel Comics
and says you guys gave Beast car Blanche
to do whatever it is that he wanted to
do right to operate however it is he
needed to operate and naturally it
became too much for him he became more
and more extreme a darker and darker
version of himself and now he's just a
straight up villain and so we're
initially the quiet counsel doesn't want
to see Wolverine go on a war path and
basically eradicate any version of Beast
that exists out there the reality here
is they're not going to stop him because
they know enough not to they're smart
enough to know Wolverine is not the guy
you stuck you let Wolverine Jewish thing
and you clean up the mess afterwards
because Wolverine is too important of an
asset to be let go he's one of the very
few mutants that exist out there in
Marvel Comics that doesn't actually need
the mutant nation of krakowa it gives
them a sense of home and it makes him
feel like he belongs somewhere but he
can make it out there in the world by
himself he would just take off to the
Canadian wilderness and just live out
there for a while and that would
basically just be it and so what this
does is this switches over to Maverick
now Maverick was at one point a teammate
of Wolverine in Marvel Comics back
before Wolverine had adamantium bonded
to his body when he was on a group
called team X so him and Maverick have
known each other for an incredibly long
time but Maverick has also been stealing
from kirkoa specifically for Cohen
flowers that allow for enhanced
abilities or curing cancer any number of
effects and so because of this Beast is
trying to have Maverick kill now one of
the things to know is this guy's
ridiculously capable so much so this guy
could capture Wolverine if he wanted to
he's probably one of the most capable
mercenaries in the entire priority of
Marvel Comics I mean even guys like
Taskmaster recognize how capable
Maverick is so you don't just go after
him right I mean you've really really
got to be careful when you do so where
these other Wolverines all show up here
they kill all of Maverick's henchmen and
then kill Maverick himself or at least
go after Maverick himself he's able to
get the upper hand he basically survives
the experience and he ends up taking one
of the Wolverines with him the funny
thing here is that Beast doesn't know it
and Beast thinks that Maverick's dead he
chalks the whole thing up and says
whatever we're done here because what
you end up getting is Maverick
underwater watching as Beast and the
other Wolverines go on a retrieval
mission for the Wolverine that Maverick
had taken literally he just leaves that
version of Wolverine there is just kind
of a chance to watch and see what they
do when they get close enough Maverick
detonates the submarine blows the whole
thing up and kills that version of beast
in the process but he doesn't fully
understand everything that's going on he
takes that version of Wolverine with him
goes back to his base of operations none
the wiser to the fact that there are
still other beasts and they're all
operating according to the same mindset
now they're basically a council at this
point in time and so while Maverick is
sitting there with this version of
Wolverine the prime Wolverine shows up
here the reason for this is because he
knew that Maverick would be one of the
targets of beasts so either Beast got to
him already or beast would get to him
eventually and that would give Wolverine
the chance to basically go through
Maverick to get to Beast himself and so
it's one of these cool moments here
because with the two of them working
together they come to this realization
or at least Wolverine explains Beast has
gone Rogue he's gonna end up triggering
some kind of a world war between the
human population and mutants themselves
they've got to find a way to take this
guy out but for his actions lead to the
ruin of all and so you switch over to
the Council of beasts right you've got
Prime beast and the other beast and
after all talking the Prime beast is
talking about how they've had a lot of
successful missions everything's going
off without a hitch all that kind of
stuff here's the problem Prime beast is
not accounting for the one thing that he
should have accounted for by giving
these different versions of an
self-autonomy they eventually start to
think for themselves they start to come
up with their own philosophies
ideologies and while it's not
necessarily them just defecting and
going off on their own way what they do
is start to realize small things that
where Prime beast leaves after
dismissing the council itself this
Council of Beast looks around and they
say okay something bigger is going on
here if you guys notice he made a change
to us when he created us he gave us
nearsightedness just this small little
thing to show us that we're not quite on
his level what this is is this is the
development of resentment right this is
the development of the very seeds that
will lead to them trying to kill beasts
and so what Beast Prime does is he calls
the entire Council into a room and he
says I do have one final mission that we
need to implement and when they ask what
it is he instructs the Wolverines to
kill every single one of those beasts
because seemingly he's realized it's
only a matter of time before they turn
against him and so what he does is he
says clean up the messes burn the bodies
I'm gonna go back and I'm going to
recreate these guys and I'm going to
make them more loyal and so you switch
over to a guy named Jeff Bannister now
Jeff banister is basically the current
friend of Wolverine but also has
contacts in the CIA and works with a
kind of anti-mutant task force and so
it's one of these things where the enemy
of my enemy is my friend that sure the
anti-mutant task force under any normal
circumstance would go directly after
Wolverine Prime beast Prime and even
Maverick it's one of these things where
they all basically end up outlying
themselves with Wolverine Prime and
Maverick Prime because beats Prime is
the main threat here so again you're
right the enemy of my enemy is my friend
now as they're going through with their
mission they're literally trying to find
the base of operations for Beast himself
that one of the contacts right one of
the members in these jets these Pilots
contacts Jeff Bannister and says Target
located right we found one of the
Wolverine clones all the while
completely unaware of the fact that it's
the actual Wolverine alongside Maverick
so where they initially fire on these
guys you end up having Warren who
figures out really fast okay this is
Jeff bannister's guys they're gonna wipe
us out we have to find some way to get
in contact with them so what he does is
he ends up jumping on a kind of radio
and then getting a hold of Jeff now
where Jeff initially thinks that he's
one of the Clones that Wolverine reveals
some intimate details that only Jeff
would know right that his daughter is
his whole world that Jeff himself drinks
like a sailor and so that's enough
because of the fact that they've shared
you know a friendship and drunk in the
backyard and all that kind of stuff Jeff
realizes it's the actual Wolverine he
calls off the attack and then says what
do we do right how do we handle this but
before they're able to figure out a
solution and even muster any measure of
an attack at least emerges out of the
ocean in this giant suit right like this
just the point as a living robot blows
every single ship out of the sky
eradicates what forces Jeff banister had
he's forced to retreat Maverick and
Wolverine Escape by the skin of their
teeth and they end up in some small
island town in Norway and then one of
the Wolverine clones show up with it's
basically a message they initially think
it's a bomb and they effectively kill
him but it turns out to be a message
it's actually a beast getting a hold of
Wolverine and saying let's sit down and
let's have a conversation and what you
get here is this really cool moment
where Beast explains what his motivation
is and why he's doing all of this he
even goes so far as to explain like yes
I know this could lead to World War
Three that's fine because it's worth the
risk the reality here is that by wiping
out any and all opposition to the mutant
population that we basically Safeguard
our very existence we send a message to
everybody out there do not mess with the
mutant population the responsive will
reign is that's not going to work
because we've seen what happens when it
does and he's right those of you guys
who don't know what I'm referencing I'm
referencing one of the most significant
stories in the history of the X-Men
Mythos when mystique and her Brotherhood
of evil mutants executed professor
Charles Xavier of the X-Men the leader
of the team Mora McTaggart a mutant
geneticist and Senator Robert Kelly on
national television as a display of the
might of the mutant population
attempting to send the same message do
not mess with mutants what did that lead
to Days of Future Past where the signals
took over North America it was the worst
possible outcome for the mutant
population and that's where despite
everything that it is that Beast is
saying Wolverine just remains staunchly
silent he's not listening to anything
this guy has to say it's like you have
no idea what you're talking about and he
even tries to reason with him and he's
like this isn't you man this is not you
Hank I don't know how you got this way I
don't know why you're operating this way
but this is not you now one of the
things about this is I still stand by
the theory this is not actually Beast
this is dark Beast right beast from an
alternate reality who was a really dark
and sadistic version of the character
that we know this is exactly what he
would do so I really feel like this is
not actually the Hank McCoy that we know
and so what Beast also reveals is that
he has Jeff banister and so he literally
says like if you stay away I stay away
as long as you stay out of my way you
can have Jeff Van Mr back and I promise
you I won't go after him I won't go
after you I won't go after his daughter
right everything will be cool and you
guys will effectively be safe I mean but
this leads to Wolverine going back to
the base of operations with Maverick
where they have a few of these Wolverine
clones in a cell and what they start to
realize is these Wolverine clones are
starting to talk they're not able to
make like complete sentences they're
able to say things like bub out might
let us out kill you like they're able to
form sentences they weren't designed to
be that way they were designed to be
docile primitive and incapable of
thinking for themselves the hypothesis
that Wolverine has is their healing
factors starting to kick in and is
starting to build neurons inside their
brain getting them to a place where they
can function on a normal level and when
Maverick asks what does this mean the
response of Wolverine is Beast has
literally surrounded himself with an
Arsenal that could turn on him at any
moment and woe be tied the world if an
army of wolverines with the same the
level of thinking and ferocity that I
have spread throughout the globe because
there'll be almost no way to find them
and there'll be almost no way to stop
them it really would turn into a
circumstance where Wolverine would kill
the Marvel Universe with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you all for watching and I will
catch you all later peace